nashville tennessee lexington kentucky
thank you so much for all the love it
was great to see you all out there i
really appreciate all the support i am
bringing the night pants nation tour to
boston march 31st to april 2nd
and minneapolis april 28th through the
30th get your tickets for those shows
and all shows at ryansickler.com
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i want to say as i do every
week thank you for your support here um
please hit the subscribe button on the
youtube y'all how can i help the show
ryan i don't have a lot of money it's
free you're watching it right now hit
the subscribe button it means nothing to
you it means everything to all of us all
right
the patreon is going nowhere the
honeydew with you all is one of my
favorite things to do i love my job and
y'all have not let me down if you or
someone you know out there has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com okay
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you're getting over a month
free and you're getting the honeydew a
day early ad-free at no additional cost
all right you guys know what we do over
here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers today's guest first
time here
very excited to have him on the honeydew
y'all ladies and gentlemen rory scoville
welcome to the honeydew roy yeah thank
you this is a long time thanks for
having me yeah thanks for being here i
don't i don't like eating honeydew and i
just realized that whole picture behind
the whole point just staring at it
just throw the [ __ ] away people love it
people like that they like
you see this one
somebody at their job caught this dog
passing up perfectly good honey dude
here you go
yeah
and that one right there the honeydew
with the cigarette yeah exactly that's
the stuff that's sticking around yeah uh
i'm well good this makes me feel like i
i fit right in
here a perfect welcome yeah
okay excuse me first before we begin
please plug promote everything and
anything you'd like you got it uh i
myself have a podcast with daniel van
kirk called
wherever you get your
podcast which i don't know where even
those places are but wherever that is uh
look us up give us a go see if you like
what we're doing um and then i'm on a
show called physical on apple tv plus
with uh rose byrne so
i'd say those two things all right what
about your social media website any of
that
rory scoville for all that stuff rory
scoville.com but i have not i'm not like
you i have not been on the road in
so long i don't even know if i can fully
remember
what that space even feels like so if
someone does go to rory scoville.com
look past the fact that it's not updated
in any way and also don't go to the tour
dates and see that i probably haven't
even deleted things from 2018 like oh
he's coming to toronto
look at that year look at the year
before you buy click buy a lot of
expiration dates yeah
well i'm not like you i've never been in
a movie or a series so see what i mean
you don't need a dot com maybe you don't
need the dot com i don't know if any of
us needed any i feel like social media
is the new like free space to just you
know i think if you go on tick-tock and
you say i'm in vancouver that almost
hits more people than the dot-com
probably
but i don't know how to play
i there's a part of me it feels like i
don't know how to play
this new game of i was already bad at
promoting myself then the game changed
for someone who already wasn't doing the
old way so there's a part of me it's
like well maybe the new way
works for me and then that's when i stop
having any tour dates so i
haven't got to experiment yet to see if
it works and i'll shift it into cars
[Laughter]
we'll see i'll get back out there i'll
get i'll get on the road well you have a
very interesting back story i do
remember from the crab feast talking
about this a little bit but there's so
much more that's happened obviously
since then that we're going to get into
yeah but death
unfortunately you like myself very
familiar with death very early on
but you very early on so your mom
died on your first birthday my mom
passed away on my first birthday okay
how how did your mom pass she had
hodgkin's disease uh so cancer and uh
now can i ask that she
did she know that while she was pregnant
or was that something that happened but
in the year she she had you yeah
it's it's interesting because and i feel
like maybe you can relate that but a lot
of people can relate to this if you've
lost someone at a young age the story
that you start to get has to come from
people
and especially for us uh you know in the
in the 80s came from people who maybe
were like well just tell him whatever
right it doesn't matter like i which i
would have done that must i would have
made that mistake too but yeah for me i
from what i can understand is that uh
she was diagnosed
had like was pregnant with me that's my
understanding
and um
was given the option to
go through chemotherapy
uh but was told that i definitely was
gonna it would it would have taken my
life and so she didn't do your mom
literally gave her life she literally
gave her life she said
she
uh from what i'm told this is how we're
starting
i have uh listen
if your life started this way yeah
this is how things start
there's good spots sometimes there's
good spots right in the middle you get
to the middle of a jelly doughnut that's
a fun space to be but to get there
you're like this is a little dry
but he's day old
but i i've had family members uh aunts
and
close family friends of my parents uh
who
you know they said that she was like no
my son will have a chance and
you know someone tells you that i think
the first time someone told me that my
mother had said that when she had
refused to do chemotherapy was
i want to say i was like late teens
early 20s but maybe late teens
and
i mean it's
i'd say that moment in her life before i
was even born
is what
pushed me to decide that whatever i was
going to do with my life i was like
building off of that that inspiration i
was like i don't think
for me
if i have a job i don't like
then i think i wasted
this moment that someone someone made
this ultimate sacrifice
um
and so i'm like you know so then i want
to do something big of course and i
it's so interesting i mean how these all
these things tie together you go i want
to do something big and so for me it
just happened to be
oh i you know i'm funny i'm a class
clown i do this and then you stumble
into stand-up and then suddenly you're
like oh this has actually kind of got
some traction but you know
in those first three years you don't
know what that kind of traction is three
well i mean i mean when you're starting
to go
exactly exactly still today tour dates
i'm like i gotta make my life special
like you haven't updated your website
go daddy's still sending you reminders
right you gotta pay for your website
your mom for a win chemo
well i can't i'm busy right now i can't
do it today i'll get it
i'll call some clubs soon
but um
yeah well you know there's this that
this motivation in the back of my mind
to be like well
i have to do something big and
extraordinary
and it isn't until
now at 41 that i've kind of been like
well i don't i don't really know what
that ever even
meant uh this like
you know like oh i'm a stand-up and i
got to do something on
live at gotham or i make money
going on the road or the opportunities
that we get in this
business you almost step back and you're
like
well only now am i like well is that the
big thing that i thought it would be
because i think i just i think i'm just
lucky to have a really cool fun
job i man i resonate hard with that
that's it like i say all the time like
we're hearing about all these [ __ ]
child predators and rapists and [ __ ] and
our our job okay right but if we worked
for fedex and that was one of the top
drivers i'm supposed to rally for that
guy
because he's a good fedex delivery guy i
mean get the [ __ ] out of here right yeah
get the [ __ ] out of here what are you
talking about
i get that what we do is different it's
unique maybe it's special yeah there's a
different thing but at the end of the
day we are the people the theater kids
don't want to hang out with we are the
[ __ ] bad news bears we are the
misfits and there is
something
[ __ ] up and mental and lovable and
funny and fun about us yeah okay
but
i'm right there with you yeah that is
who we are yeah period it may it kind of
makes you
i i think uh it really puts it in place
that you go oh this is
i'm lucky
that i have
this job and the fact that it is a job
in the past two years has taught us
you know gratitude in a huge way but at
the same time hopefully the reason why
you know i think you're successful and
many of our friends are successful even
people we don't know who are successful
is because you can tell that it's just
it's actually their personality
is there's something ingrained in them
that says
i'm not afraid of
300 strangers i'm not afraid of this
joke working or not working
i'm not afraid of what i'm wearing the
things that some people i think when
they go i could never get on stage it's
like because the 10 things you're
thinking about aren't even those don't
even cross our mind we literally are
chasing a drug that's already built into
us to go for it it isn't us going
you know oh yeah i think i got you know
when you have a new joke
that's like a drug that you can't even i
had a driver in kansas city that drove
me to the club and the guy i'm not gonna
do it now but he literally says he keeps
saying he's from wisconsin so i'm like
okay this guy wants me to ask why
i go so what brought you to kansas city
and he goes you want the prison version
or do you want to i'll follow a woman
version i was like i definitely went to
prison yeah so i have a new five-minute
[ __ ] story
about the the felon the federal felon
who rob banks right uh that drove me to
the club now yeah
yeah so
all right let's talk about a few things
here yeah how old was your mom when she
passed 25. holy [ __ ]
i'll tell you what that really changes
you too you might have gone through this
because when you hit that dude when you
hit that age you go [ __ ] that's way
younger than i've ever pictured
in my life what are you doing at 25
what's what's 25 year old rory scoville
doing just give me something during the
day
i just pot definitely smoking pot
skipping you know if i'm at work
this is what i was doing so i lived in
dc okay um and i was doing i worked for
uh i was a government worked for a
government contracting uh firm uh
contractor with the um irving burton
associates iba oh yeah and it was like
medical stuff for like vet veterans and
and things but i was just like a
secretary desktop support specialist but
it was i was a secretary i went and ran
i got i got supplies i made sure the
cover
all right
right you're the desktop support
specialist right yeah the printer needs
paper oh exactly okay executive dss yeah
the printer my pen needs ink can you
give me another pen you got it somebody
left the cap off these sharpies yeah let
me get those i got let me get those
because i'm a specialist got a rainbow
pack right here
yeah a specialist in anything is a red
flag but i uh yeah so that's what i did
i that's what i was doing in uh in dc
but you know that's under the desk i am
specifically desktop this is how
my my job was when i took calls i had to
put a notch of how many calls we got
that day and i just transferred calls my
boss was the greatest boss ever
everybody knew i did stand up they
thought oh that's great i in one of my
yearly reviews i said to my boss i was
like you don't need someone doing this i
was like you could get a machine
to answer it and he was like you're the
first person to ever come in here to
explain to me why you shouldn't have a
job
he goes you do stand up he goes do you
want me to really write this down and
take this to the higher ups like hey we
should get a robot and i was like i
guess i guess not
and that's what you're doing and your
mom
is deciding to forgo chemo at 25.
exactly what a [ __ ] decision exactly
so so in that space of being 25 i was
also that's when i started stand up was
uh 24
24 i think 23 24. um
and that's when i started getting on
stage so
there's this part of me that's living
this life of like do i have the audacity
would i ever have the courage the
bravery to ever say that to a doctor if
i was in that position but then there's
this this is part of me that's like i
have a responsibility to pursue
my own joy and happiness because of
someone gave you that yeah yeah yeah i i
think all the time too it doesn't it's
not important to me to be famous it's
not important to me to be any of that
stuff but what was important to me too
is i literally have my father and
grandmother who's gave their life for us
and there's no way i'm gonna waste it so
part of me isn't just doesn't just want
to um do what i want to do and do it to
its fullest because they were like go
live the life you want to live yeah but
the other part of me wants to
keep them alive in some way and tell
their stories and i'm i'm glad and
fortunate to be able to
tell stories in my stand-up and podcast
that have kept people kept them alive at
least for me yeah it's nice to talk
about them and [ __ ] like that so yeah
all right let's dial it back a second
here your mom's 25 your dad's
20 i believe he was 25 going on 26.
they're married yeah and is this their
first child
i'm their second sex so my sister's a
year and a half older than me okay so i
don't know when she specifically found
out that she's yeah you guys are pretty
quick back-to-back yeah i don't know
when they're like oh yeah you're you
have this long to live i don't even
remember if that was like
a thing all anyone's ever told me now is
they're like oh yeah the treatment she
could have had now would be you know she
would have survived she would have lived
but at the time they didn't know you
know it's always such a
evolving sort of game with cancer i
guess it's you know you don't know what
treatments they're gonna uncover and
what they want so basically your dad is
the diary of your mom for you yeah
we're going to get to that but i have
this one question is there anything that
sticks out that anyone in the family or
one of her friends told you about her
like um
something you're like that's [ __ ]
cool to know you know it's it's not
not even that long ago because i haven't
ever really known uh my mother one you
know yeah no there was one time i was at
my grandparents house her parents uh and
they
they were like you know we have all this
film
and i was like wait what do you mean and
they're like yeah because we had a
camera we were upset my grandfather was
obsessed with he had like the film
camera no audio but like film
and they're like you know we have a lot
of this of your mom and i was like i've
never seen her in motion like this is
absurd and i was like do you have a
projector and they were like yeah so i
remember being at their house one day
and i'm putting the projector together
i'm like jacked and i couldn't the
projector wouldn't know it was like
broken real reason i had all yeah and i
had all of those and they were just in
this box
and i didn't live in in my hometown of
greenville at the time so i was like all
right well let's we'll keep these here i
got in touch with my cousin i said can
you find someone i'll pay for all of it
go get all this transferred digitally
and it not that long ago we got all of
that transferred my sister and i got to
see her like movement which is like
what's that what was that like it's
strange because it's like uh i i mean
i don't know what it would be like to
hear her voice i think i don't think
that'll be something i'm ever able to do
i don't think in 81 you know i don't i
don't know what
she would have had you know any home
video stuff they had home cameras it
wasn't
yeah i don't know i don't know if she if
there's anything that exists but
um that was a moment but then also
maybe in
2018
i went and got
coffee in charleston south carolina with
because i was doing a show there get
this random email a friend of hers from
high school is also in town and she was
like i was friends with your mom
and i have a letter that she wrote me
before she passed away
and uh she's like i'd like to just sit
and meet you and chat and so i was like
this has never happened this is great so
i went and
sat down with her and her husband and
we chatted and she was showing me some
pictures that she had in this letter to
like see my
mother's handwriting it's it's sort of a
testament to what we do and and what
other artists i think do but like
reading her writing
is the only way i think i've i will
probably ever hear her voice is that one
letter that i've i've now read
but she said your mom
used to like steal [ __ ]
like wow
she said well this one picture we went
to to disney world and she goes your mom
uh she goes this is just after us
stealing stuff from the gift shop oh
shoot like petty fat [ __ ] yeah like tiny
[ __ ] that didn't matter
and i gotta say like you know
everyone building her up to me is your
mom was perfect she wrote yes they don't
tell you the real thing and i gotta say
it was the most
it was like the first moment that i felt
this this thing of of real where i was
like that's her yeah i was like like
tell me
the
[ __ ] up thing she said or did like
give me give me that like as opposed to
perfect which is just so hard to believe
the older you get and they were also
like uh
she used to uh help at the high school
and work in the office and she would
steal all the tardy slips and just give
them out to people to
and my whole life because of uh how my
dad
you know the level of discipline stuff i
lived this fear of doing things right
like i was the kid who in any movie i
was the kid going i don't think we
should do this guys that was my whole
life guys we're gonna get in trouble
we're friends are like what does that
even mean i'm like well at my house it's
pretty bad i don't want to [ __ ] get
in trouble so i'd like to not
participate so to find out that she was
like this i'm just like oh man i
like it it's there's something kind of
fun to know that that that sort of
mischief isn't even in my dna right it
almost feels great um
but
yeah that that that was something
recently where i was like oh this is
it it really made me go well [ __ ] now i
really want to know
this person that i'll never
know you know and then trying to figure
out
uh how to do that
is
you know it's it's
it's intense because
there's one the one guy who i could talk
to to go hey who is this woman is my dad
and
my sister and i
you know we'd check in with each other
all the time
even as two people not knowing how to
talk to each other about hey our mom's
dead so how does that make you feel you
know you know you don't have to talk
about it with anybody really you're 41
you said right yeah and you're a dad how
old your if you have a son right yeah uh
my daughter she's six yeah okay well six
oh we are the same club all right so
your daughter's six you're 41.
your dad's basically 25. yeah he's now
he's a widow yeah his wife has just died
of cancer yep he's left with basically a
three-year-old and a one-year-old yeah
what happens and can you by the way can
you imagine being 25 [ __ ] years old
you know what and all that's going on
while you're also trying to figure out
yeah how to raise a boy and a girl yeah
i it's so
funny to me i'm not funny i mean i don't
know maybe it is kind of funny but but
well what does happen at that time is
that his younger younger sister um he
was one of five kids he was the oldest
so the next kid in line my aunt connie
uh she stops college and moves in with
us and so it's my dad my aunt and my
sister and me um
and it's
it
it's strange because
losing your mother at one is something
you you can't
mentally understand but i fully
believe in the uh
the connection that you do have and i
think there is something that does
happen where you your
the cells in your body or something are
fully aware
that a trauma has occurred whether you
cannot digest that
i believe that you know it you just know
it it's just something energy yeah
there's an energy and you're like that's
gone but you don't know what that even
means right uh and then my aunt moves in
with us
and it's hard to look back and are weird
to look back on and and realize that
while people are explaining your reality
to you which is how we all live someone
has to also explain to you
know your mother you you don't have a
mother because you don't understand that
because you i've immediately shifted to
oh this is my this woman this is this
woman and this man these are my two but
this is my you know you're like a dog
you're like what's my pack where do i
stand in the back
so it was like oh this is the pack
and of course you know when you think
about something but you try to find some
positives i mean i had a great family a
big family my dad's one of five kids so
like obviously everybody
realizes like all hands on deck like
these two kids and what they're going
through like we're a family we're going
to be together we're going to you know
come in and that's my perception
grant and my dad at the time could have
been like i wished everyone [ __ ] up or
i didn't think so i didn't think so and
so did enough like i didn't see anything
i'll tell you what yeah vicky was [ __ ]
you know it you know
she should have been there like well i
don't know i'm you know one colleen was
there
probably quit college yeah
vic you don't even send gifts
don't even sit and get you didn't send
gifts
i saw at the funeral they still went
around with the collection plate
he didn't even contribute
he contribute
got a collection plate at a funeral i
don't even do catholics do that god
that's going to be
hey i know this but still
give a little bit
it's fine it's gonna be okay if you give
a little bit
yeah you gotta give to get you gotta
give to get folks
get a couple extra years on your soul
yeah so that was that was that became
our our that became my
reality and as a kid i don't understand
at all in any capacity
what my dad is is going through there's
no there's no chance even
even when you're 25 how the [ __ ] could
you unless you go through that no okay
but what
what age do you start remembering people
sort of
formulating the story for you
and who was it yeah i i don't know i i
don't
i my assumption and i'd have to ask
family members like hey right away were
you guys constantly informing us that
aunt connie is not your mom because
no matter what whether i was told that
you start to form a bond with some
maternal there's a maternal thing
happening there even for her we aren't
her kids but she's now a mother to two
kids that aren't her kids uh it's i'm
sure it's a strange
place to be but
we were
you know my assumption was like you're
my person
you know that that's where my soul was
and then my dad remarried when i was in
the second grade and so then that
there was just a sudden shift where that
my aunt now was like all right back to
school to finish my you know degree to
become a teacher
and now here i am with living with a
stepmother and it's that is a such a
strange
space to be in that i've i've said that
to my sister and so i mean different
kind of divorce yeah where i've told
people i'm like i don't i don't think i
don't know if our family
if it registers for a family maybe it
does that that is
two traumas that is kind of like losing
too much of my mom yeah yeah and i i i
have so many
i have so many memories of
my aunt coming to visit
and you know we're in i remember this
one time
and this is where my memory gets a
little hazy because i know for a fact i
was in the first grade but i also know
that she had already moved to florence
south carolina but i also know that my
dad got married in second grade so i
don't know i'm hazy in in the timeline
of why and what but i remember one day
she took us to school before she was
gonna drive back to florence
and we were just parked in the car
and
just sitting there and you you know this
space we everybody knows this space
you're sitting there
and you're in this sad moment and you
know that i was in first grade and i
i can like remember just kind of like
almost shaking like
oh i know she's about to leave
and this to me is my mother right and i
know she's about to leave
and i'm i'm gonna get worked up here
but
we get out of the car um
to walk to the the lines you know you
get in before you go into the school
and i just remember
i dropped all of my stuff and i looked
at her and i was like i don't want you
to go
and i think back now like [ __ ] how
i think one for me like
that's a traumatizing moment yeah but
her
i think in that moment like
i relate to that more now where if my
daughter said that to me like and for
whatever reason i don't want you to
leave oh
i i don't know what i like it's almost
like someone just stabbed you yeah and
you you don't even scream you just are
like in the shock of it but i remember
dropping all my stuff i'm crying i'm
like i don't want you to leave and she's
like i gotta leave and then
whatever transpires i end up getting in
the line i remember being in school i'm
crying and
i don't even know what if i only now do
i look back at this like even if you're
the teacher and someone goes well you
know his mom died on his first birthday
this aunt moved in to take care of him
anyway she's got to go back to
work so anyways he's sad about that i if
if you're the teacher are you just like
hey here's a pile of candy because i
can't even fat like i was over here
going oh i forgot to i'm 36 and i've
never gone i'm over here going my vcr's
broken yeah that's what i thought that
was a thing but now this kid's sick and
so i think i feel stuff like that even
more because like i said my daughter is
in that age and i i constantly record
where she's at in her life and where i
was at
and it gives me this strange trauma that
doesn't relate to her
but i experience through where i'm like
oh that's where i almost start to cry
like on her first birthday i cried in
bed and my wife was like
she i remember i got home i was probably
doing a spot or something and i got home
and the next day was her birthday party
and her first birthday and i was just
crying and i remember my wife being like
what are you okay and i was like
i only now know
what one year looks like right i now
know
oh you were born
365 days and that's it and it's a fine
it's it's almost like
a finite number you know you've been
talking like let's think about your mom
for a second this is a 25 year old woman
yeah who knows she's dying yeah and
there's a moment in her life where she
looks at you guys for the last time or
know she's never gonna see you guys grow
up or anything and i'm just over here
thinking that is a parent right now like
oh yeah the [ __ ]
like if cancer isn't bad enough you know
what i mean
they told me and this is what's
interesting to me too and everyone kind
of develops their story my aunt told me
my aunt connie told me this at one point
she goes so you she goes your mother
collapsed in the bathroom
of the hospital room that she was in um
because she had a heart attack and she
collapsed and so i remember when she
told me that i was like
so did she die of a heart attack and my
aunt goes not to me to me it was the
cancer that killed her and i remember
going
that is so important that it it
nothing against my aunt but i remember
it made me angry to decide that this
story that matters so much to who i am
and where i come from
to decide like yeah but i think it was
this now as i've gotten older i look
back and i go you know what i i can
understand her perspective of
the cancer whatever it was going through
whatever treatment she was doing i'm
sure it made it so weak that you know
maybe in a normal world she doesn't have
a heart attack at all right so then you
go well that's what i mean by it taking
it but i just i so i say all that to to
say that i don't know if there was ever
this last moment of like oh i'm not
gonna get out of here and this will take
me i i truly think that my family might
have thought i see she's gonna be fine
okay and i think
this all comes from the story that
people tell you that i think we were
going to myrtle beach we were supposed
to go to myrtle beach and i for some
reason i feel like someone's told me a
story that we were gonna like pick her
up to like go
to the beach so i i'm hazy on what
everyone's expectations were of her
recovering or not recovering but i do
know that
my dad was at home
with us my aunt tells me this and got a
must have gotten a phone call because
she goes i walked in the door
and she's like your dad threw the two of
you at me almost like in the most
dangerous way you could ever pass two
kids off to somebody he was like i gotta
go he was like out the door and off to
the hospital and
man the older i get the more i think
what is that like what is that space
once when you get that phone call
what i think about it so much now like
what was that drive
from starting your car no texts how are
you how do you see the road behind just
your mind yeah and you the radio is not
on you're just driving and there's lying
you're just there's no way you're not
looking at it through a stained glass
window out your windshield like the
tears are just taken over and i
i've thought about that
more and more my as i've aged my brain
asked better questions about what what
happened in these moments as opposed to
oh yeah he threw it and then he drove
off right my brain has now become more
of that journalist of like god i wonder
what that drive was like a question i
never had drive does he know that she's
gone and yeah what would they fail for
the rest of your life i've got two kids
how am i going to do this yeah yeah yeah
yeah so what your dad was alive or he
died recently my dad died in june of
2020. so we are recently sorry four
months into
covet i guess and he had a heart attack
and passed away because it also is
important to know if your mom died if
she had that cancer is that hereditary
all kinds of things that you need to
know not just for you but your dog my
grandfather had a heart attack my aunt
connie who is still alive she's had a
heart attack and you just go hey heart
stuff
did she ever get that degree
she got the time he got that degree way
to go
she got it she taught she's retired
she's moved on she's at the beach
a little two-year hiatus take care of
you guys
did she stay present in your life after
that would you been being present yeah
yeah obviously it was a day to day
originally yeah we would see her and uh
and and spend time with her and i think
my sister and i have sort of a unique
uh aunt niece nephew relationship
because it's
you know i mean
more so
i mean to all of us because we all feel
it but you know more so to her because
she's she was of an age to really
remember that time period whereas my
sister and i it's more something you
just feel um and you kind of maintain
over time but
yeah there's three phases of things i
want to talk about i want to talk about
your dad first yeah i want to talk about
this your stepmom who came in at the
time i'm just saying this so i don't
forget yeah and then i want to talk
about because your mom's parents were
alive when she passed right so that
you've got
her parents and your dad is sort of
these living diaries to ask questions
and
um start with your dad like when at what
age do you remember like a real
conversation with your dad about your
mom never never we never had one you
were you always scared to ask i was
terrified it wasn't that he would shut
it down you just never asked i he never
shut it down in fact when i was when
those uh
those reel to reels when those got
converted to digital and i could
actually see video of my of my mother on
a on a dvd
um
i remember i was visiting my sister in
virginia
my dad was there with my stepmom and and
i i can't remember if i was in town
doing shows but i think i was just like
oh this is kind of bizarre that all of
us are up at my sister's place because
that just never happens
and she maybe
i can't remember what it was if it was
one of her kids or something
but anyways my sister goes let's put on
one of those dvds which was such a in
front of my dad which was like such a
moment of like is this hap like i was
terrified and excited by it because i
think
instinctually as his kids i think my
sister and i always
carried this sense of protecting him
from that and i don't i don't know why
but i think we were all just always like
we know how we feel and
we know who you are and how you are and
i think there was this this place of
like
we won't bring this sadness to you have
you ever just been too damn high with
today's weed it can be a dangerous game
and we don't always have time to play
reefer roulette when we're looking to
light up dad grass is reviving the
pleasure of the casual smoke so you can
chill out without the stress daggrass is
legal organic smokable hemp that relaxes
your body and mellows your mind their
100 percent organic pre-rolled joints
are very low in thc and high in cbd so
you can enjoy the effects of cbd while
keeping a clear head want the toke
without the smoke dad grass also has a
cbd tincture made with the same high
quality hemp it's easy to dose and the
effects come on smooth chill out without
getting stoned it's like having a glass
of wine not the whole bottle all
daggrass products are federally legal
for ages 18 and over and it ships right
to your door anywhere in the u.s whether
you're looking for a new buzz or a chill
way to enjoy an old favorite dag grass
will leave you in a euphoric mood right
now dadgrass is offering my listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com honeydew go to dadgrass.com
honeydew for 20 off your first order
that's d-a-d-g-r-a-s
dot com slash honeydewdadgrass.com
honeydew a lot of people didn't even
make resolutions this year and you know
what i get it but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't still find a way to shake
things up whether it's by switching up
your workout routine or going someplace
new whatever way you challenge yourself
this new year there's no better way to
do it than with the pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears raycon
wireless earbuds are the best way to
bring audio with you because no matter
how you shake things up literally no
matter how you shake you know they won't
fall out of your ears
their everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever there's also
awareness mode for when you need to
listen to your surroundings so you can
take raycons with you wherever you go
with optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me mine never fall out i know you
guys are loving raycons they wouldn't
keep coming back if you didn't so that's
a testament to itself all right raycons
offer eight hours of playtime and a
32-hour battery life and they're priced
just right you get quality audio at half
the price of other premium audio brands
it's no wonder raycon's everyday earbuds
have over 48 thousand five star reviews
right now honeydew listeners can get 15
percent off their recon order at
buyracon.com honeydew that's buy
ratecon.com honeydew to save fifteen
percent on raycon's buy ratecon.com
honeydew our friends at manscape the
global leaders in below the waist
hygiene are turning men's shower dreams
into their favorite routine with the
all-new premium collection this
all-in-one hygiene skin and hair bundle
is designed to upgrade the everyday man
shower routine from head to toe your
skin hair and balls deserve this save
big by going to manscape.com for 20 off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew we're going to use that
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer to clean
off any unwanted body hair the lawnmower
4.0 is waterproof so you bet it's a
major key to the new shower routine this
new bundle will change your life and i
want all of my listeners out there to
live their best lives get 20 off plus
free shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com
get 20 off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code
honeydew at
manscape.com it's time to get wet and
clean with your new manscape shower
routine now let's get back to the duke
so that moment of first saying let's
let's watch this
was a big deal and we watched it and
obviously there's tons of video popping
up you're watching your dad watching you
know i'm doing the like clock you know
trying to not turn the head to make it
obvious like yeah i just want to see how
you're reacting
um
well he was fine i i think
i i think what
and i don't know this but i think what
happens is is you
you ha you have to move on you have to
go
this was that life
and now this is this life and i think my
dad sat there and he could have easily i
mean ripe moment to like have asked
questions and you know say some stuff my
first tattoo nothing like she looks like
you or you're not not getting nothing
out of it nothing no nothing and i and
like i said i mean there's this instinct
of going well i'm not gonna ever push
this
push this issue is your dad in these
videos as well
look there you go
he's not saying like i remember that
birthday he's not saying yeah
he's not he's not sitting there shut
down okay he is sitting there commenting
and saying some stuff and i think that
made me and my sister
feel really good i mean us sitting down
having a conversation with them is
something that we've talked about for a
very long time in our lives and yeah
never try to double team them and go at
it we just never set it up it just was
this what are you scared of you said you
were scared to death what of what so i i
i think hurting him i think
seeing him
think about it and hurt
there's this one time we're at myrtle
beach and
me and my sister and my dad used to like
play i mean my dad really focused on
making sure
like hey i'm gonna be there
and
we were playing in the in the water i
feel like it was like
going into the evening sun's like kind
of going down and we're just having the
best time
in the water and my dad just like
stopped
and i i remember you know when kids got
that energy they don't understand like
the stop and i remember he was like
clearly something had just shifted
and he got up and and
and that was
that was kind of it it was like sort of
this i'm gonna go i'm gonna go in or
whatever and i
i remember
being like oh i don't like i think we
were both confused if maybe we did
something or if we were in trouble and i
i remember
like my grandmother his mother yeah get
him in a nuts violence yeah one of it
was just maybe that
i mean that hot [ __ ] joke isn't funny
anymore and he's feeling
my grandmother
my grandmother said uh uh to us so
casually she's like i heard your dad
lost uh
your mom's ring in the ocean
and
that he had to wear it around he had on
a necklace just through and the whatever
the necklace had come off or whatever
and i just remembered
i then started to play that back in my
mind the moment of like him like oh
we're having so much fun and then like
and it's the ocean it's gone and you're
like there's no
there's no finding this and i i was so
young
so it was definitely so prevalent
that that symbol
and i've i've thought about that moment
too where i just like god that
even that like i you think like well
what do you want what are the ways to
bring it up what are the ways to talk to
your dad i got to say
for people listening to this who maybe
you're in this position and you feel
these kind of things
the day that you will finally figure out
how to talk about these things is the
day you can't do it and it's not
over time it is literally thanos
snapping his fingers and every question
you wanted to know
just unblurs and it is so crystal clear
that i realized
the day my dad died uh
i was like this whole time i've wanted
to ask him
about uh my mom
and it's only now that i realized like
oh
that isn't the way in
the way in was to ask him about him yeah
the way in was to say
when you were going to the hospital
what what were you thinking right and
then just
listen and go
if if me asking you that
isn't the biggest sign as opposed to i
remember i had so much anger of like
don't you understand how important it is
for us to know and i almost put it on
him like to pull us aside and go hey
here's you know it's not that he would
never
mention something and when my
grandparents would come over right he
was there and it was just like yeah i
understand this was just that type of
did you have a sex talk with her dad
never my dad would never in a million
years so he's probably that he's not
that guy yeah he's not that guy and my
dad was awesome give it up my dad was
not a macho machismo guy my dad was like
a clown he would do jokes he would look
silly he dressed
so badly but thought he looked great
and and he also didn't live
yeah yeah but it's great that's how you
that's how you should be i it also
another thing like when he passed away i
was like
god i don't think i ever gave my dad
enough credit for doing and living and
and you know he had obviously we all
have our negatives but some of those
positives that didn't just highlight his
positives and go
man it's great that you i like i'm
embarrassed that i have to stand next to
you dressed like that because you truly
look so crazy he came to one of my shows
at the charlotte comedy zone
in
uh
it's cold it's winter
in uh
crew socks with adidas sandals like he's
some sort of [ __ ] soccer player from
the 90s he's going to like
going to a tournament
he's going to a tournament
he's about to put his [ __ ] songs on
and he's wearing basketball shorts and a
hoodie my aunt coaches uh coached uh
college basketball so he's got on the
gulf coast commodores hoodie
and and just i i was like i remember i
came out of the green room i go stop i
got to take a picture of you stand right
there and he's just like
and he and i mean we hung out afterwards
we're at a bar and he's dressed like
that and i just can't i'm like i i i'm
just like do you know what you look like
my whole life
my dad
popped his collar
my entire life
there wasn't a time in my life my dad
didn't have his collar popped
and we made so much fun of him and then
here comes the early 2000s where
kids are like popping their collars
and my dad goes
who do you think started that what do
you think who do you think
they got that from
and i'm sitting there going i can't even
argue this because
now that is like a look
yeah it's your dad's got that athleisure
that's what they call it now athleisure
that's it one of his friends from work
uh when i was home for the funeral and
just being back home he i remember she's
like you know she was like you know they
don't make them like your dad anymore
she goes your dad
could sit here and talk sports and and
get into an argument and and get fired
up she goes and then all the ladies at
work she goes if they all started
talking about some kind of recipe she
goes your dad's right there talking
about the recipe and what he would do
and if he just she was like your dad
wasn't
a a guy she goes your dad was a true
gentleman he really was now granted like
i said we all have our negatives like
your dad was a gentleman but she goes he
could transition i mean my dad legit
you know he he was a voice uh or or
cared about uh the voiceless he cared
about people that needed help my dad
gave blood and plasma
all the time i mean his his whole life
i've known him to go and do that i mean
we had to tell
the blood center when he had passed away
i mean they almost like oh that's like a
co-worker that's pastor passed away
um
you know i remember
he would uh my brother was telling me
this he would tell kids in our
neighborhood who had to wait on the
school bus
he goes he told them i don't ever lock
my car he goes so if it's raining and
it's cold then you're waiting on the bus
he goes just sit in my car
and i'm just like
like never time i wouldn't know
my dad's car was broken into
probably 30 times
so he just he would open the trunk he
loved tennis he would open the trunk
where he had some pretty decent rackets
and he goes look they even take these
rackets he goes they took maybe a dollar
25 and change and my license i mean my
dad drove [ __ ] cars he took pride in the
fact that his car was a pile of [ __ ] and
he'd be like who even breaks into this
car he goes they took this he goes
he goes i won i won i still got the
rackets like that that
he's that kind of person going back to
like did we ever have a sex talk
it wasn't my dad going well i'm not
gonna have a sex drive i think my dad
was
embarrassed and wouldn't have known how
to talk about it in in general but
you know i i have a little bit of that
uh in me in in terms of the emotionally
opening up and and and saying how i feel
about stuff like i i definitely probably
get a little bit of that from from his
dna where i i just don't know how to do
it and i yeah i i it is the wildest
thing and it's probably just what life
is but i could do it in a heartbeat now
because he's gone and it's it
you realize how to ask questions about
your mom suddenly you realize how to out
ask questions about him you realize
what you should have celebrated about
him to him you realize what all of the
things
just you just see the matrix suddenly
you see all the [ __ ] green numbers
and you're like oh that's what i should
have done or what i should have said and
so no now let me ask you all the years
not one thing so what's the one thing
your father said about your mom that's
that sticks with you
no matter what age i mean what is this i
mean my dad would just tell stories
about high school okay um so they were
high school sweethearts they went all
the way back yeah but it it was never
you know your mom your mom would do this
or your mom would say this your mom
would do that i remember
i think i i don't know what the answer
would have been but i i there was a part
of me that always wanted to just ask him
hey do you do you think she would have
thought i was funny do you think she
would have laughed at this stuff that i
do that's you know pretty
r-rated like this cursing like i
for a while thought well this angel
probably would have been like
you know that's for you right
and then when i found out that she was
more like
you know my dad i mean this example my
dad not open up i put out a show
uh robby on comedy central ended up
being on youtube all the all the
episodes and uh
i it came out in i think in may of 2020.
it just got dumped on youtube because
you know pandemic viacom fighter
everybody blah blah blah
and uh you know i all those episodes
came out uh i got
to the funeral
and
uh
my stepmother goes your dad your dad
liked your show
and i was just like you know they hit
you
because there's so much of him in that
show specifically that i chose like
moments of things
that were meant to be for him and about
him to some degree
and uh
yeah uh she said oh she liked her show
and i was like it only dawned on me
right there i was like i didn't he never
told me about it like he had a lietz he
had some time to say hey i don't even
know if he watched it i didn't even know
if he watches you oh your dad liked your
show and then i i remember getting a
little bit angry i wish i would have
known that and then uh
the
the
the funeral i mean the amount of
co-workers and friends who came up and
they were like your dad wouldn't shut up
about your show your dad he he some
friends said your dad called me every
day
and asked have you watched it yet and i
had you know they would just be like
honey i'll get to it when i get to
get to my dad all right and then call
the next day like well it drops at
midnight yeah did you watch it
yeah you gotta watch it
and i i you know someone tells you that
and i
i
you go i love that i love that but i i
wish and my regret is like why i wish we
had that space where my dad called me as
opposed to that i the amount of friends
in his life that are like
man your dad doesn't shut up about you
kids
if you told that to me and my i'm one of
seven kids so me and my sister and then
i have five half siblings okay uh when
he remarried and you told that he had
five more he had five more kids holy
[ __ ] they didn't stop catholic yeah the
jim gaffigan was like five kids catholic
it is um but uh yeah
he if you told that to any of us that we
would all go what are you even talking
about right like our dad doesn't pick up
the phone to just go what's going on in
your life how's it going like you call
him or if he calls on my stepmother
we're calling oh your dad wanted to talk
to you just go did you watch the game
the other day blah blah blah and you
just go why don't you just pick up the
phone and call me and ask me this stuff
but then i realized you know i didn't i
didn't do those things
um
either but that that's that's how he was
when people were like your dad doesn't
shut up about you guys we're all like i
wish i could have felt that or not i
wish i'd known that two days ago yeah
you know
so what second grade your dad remarries
for you yeah what is it like and and is
this stepmom the same lady when he had
that were they they were together the
whole time yeah yeah yeah so what um
what is that like having her come in it
was strange it was a strange i mean i'm
sure it was strange for her too you're
talking about people who are who are in
their late 20s you know because she's
younger than my dad so she was like two
kids 20s and taking on two kids who are
now uh third grade and second grade and
they dated for i think
two or three years maybe maybe more so
it which there was like a slow
transition of like oh we know who this
person is
but now she moves in and um
yeah i mean they they had my next sister
pretty
soon like a year later i guess and then
became a child-making factory
but uh yeah the the relationship uh
uh
is
is fine i think it's a strange one
given
all of the circumstances and also my
aunt who is still like you know very
much we are still her kids in a way do
you feel loyalty to her like
yeah yeah for sure i think there's a
loyalty to my aunt and then also
trying to get into this relationship
with a stepmother who's in her late 20s
and doesn't you know i don't think
they're
i don't know that anyone in my family
ever sort of clocked the
the trauma
for what me and my i think they were
just like well they're kids or they
thought well you know they'll be fine
like we'll spoil them i don't think
people
in my family and i'm you know i'm just
guilty probably with my daughter but
really clock you know
the the trauma that we're more aware of
now like we're just more aware of mental
health now and what it means and how you
can you know be better for yourself and
things that you should do i mean i've
thought so long like now we really
should have seen a therapist or a
psychologist just get us talking about
our feelings
because i think i'd be a different
person
uh today it's only today that i really i
mean really dealing with the trauma of
my mother's death didn't really happen
until my daughter was born and i was
like oh i'm in it now and now i realize
if you told me that i was gonna die and
i am looking at my daughter like that
that's insane that's i mean that's like
a genuine fear that i have because i've
lived it i have it so i'm like
oh if something happens to me i know
what that's like and i wouldn't wish
that on someone who to my face spit in
my face and told me they hate me i would
go i still wouldn't wish
you to know what this ever feels like
it's it's too it's just a big question
mark so is there any part of you as then
as a child or even growing up that feels
because i'm asking you this because i
did like a loser like my mom's gone here
goes aunt connie now this lady's coming
in do you you ever feel like you don't
have your feet under you and you're just
like this
you know yeah and then here come five
other kids do you feel like a throw away
no i don't think that ever i think
there's there's a little bit of that
that that that comes and goes for sure i
mean i love my
my brothers and sisters so much your dad
did a really good job making you guys
all
inclusive i think so but i also think
i'm sorry no was he have you ever talked
to your brothers and sisters was he the
same way with them so that's the thing
because you gotta you gotta think and
you can relate to this where you you
think to yourself
you know if if i'm you know my daughter
was born when i was 35
if i had another kid today and i'm 41
i'm like well i'm a different first year
dad than i was when i was 35 and you got
to think you know my my youngest brother
when my dad passed away was i think 22.
um
i think that's right i think he was 22
21 or 22 and you just think you know him
and my dad were like buddies right where
we look back we're like what is that how
is it like that and it's like well look
at my dad's age i mean at a certain
point he's like i yeah it worked out for
the other side quit sitting here [ __ ]
worrying about just be like yeah you oh
you don't want to go to do the thing
that i said to do i don't [ __ ] care
you know i mean you're just a different
person so i think we all probably got a
different version of a dab but i i i've
my sister and i have i've thought about
it and she sort of presented this idea
to me was that
you know what we didn't get was a dad
who sort of aged
with us who understood like
oh you're in your 30s now so this is the
this is who i am to you
at 30 or you're you know i we all had
fine relationships but i think all seven
of us are probably sitting here going
man we're really
there's a there's a big thing lacking or
missing uh from our psychology of this
relationship because uh um
because you you kept having kids you had
to keep being a young dad to these young
kids well we're like well i'm
you know i'm 35 now and i just had a kid
and it's like my dad's like well my
son's still in high school yeah you know
yeah
that's a good it's a it's a it's a weird
space to be in and to connect on you
know
yeah he's going to [ __ ] high school
yeah
um all right so now tell me about your
mom's parents were you close with them
and and were you able to communicate
better with them or were they sort of
not open as as well i think it was a
different
i think we were in just different spaces
i it's kind of shocking for them too
anything about you're like oh our
connection our liaison to our
grandchildren
is gone and so it's almost like you know
they have to make a big effort to go hey
we're gonna come and pick up the kids
we're gonna spend time with the kids
we're gonna do stuff and did that and
they did they did it all the time they
really made it a point to do it and i
they would obviously talk about my mom
well that's all they have left of their
child like forget about the liaison yeah
you are what they have left of their own
daughter and that's every [ __ ]
nightmares and lose their child and now
you guys are all they have left so did
they stay local your whole life they
stayed local they lived in my sense my
hometown and you know they had they had
three daughters my mom was their middle
child
and uh yeah i mean they would they would
willingly show us stuff pictures of our
mom talk about our mom did they have any
videos where you heard a voice no no no
never i if that exists i don't know
where it is it's funny you said that a
couple christmases ago i went back to
baltimore i was visiting some relatives
like we found this vhs you're not going
to believe this they put it in my
grandmother's on it i immediately i
start crying of course and when i hear
her voice
it's
slightly higher
pitched than i remembered it yeah and it
blew me away when i started for my first
thought was oh my god she sounds a
little different than my memory but then
i started thinking about and i was like
i don't really hear my grandmother's
voice i hear my voice saying what she
said in my head i've never really
thought and then i wondered i wonder if
my dad sounds like i remember my
father's sounding i was like man it blew
me away it was really yeah it tripped me
out a little bit yeah well you must have
stuff of your dad where you can hear
you know no video stuff
he died in 89 and i think someone that
might have a vhs is also dead right yeah
but there's old um
[Music]
and it's um you know christmas videos
where you don't hear anything and
somebody's putting their hand on the
face
that's right yeah yeah a chevy chase up
in the [ __ ] attic on christmas
vacation that's what i have that's right
yeah
yeah
um so i've watched it and and i have
that on dvd now too as well but yeah um
you know
it's
it just sucks you have all these people
there and and this one woman who's not
do you have a picture of your mom in
your home uh yeah yeah yeah you have one
of your wallets no i did my
i got a couple tucked away behind this
mama presented some doubles
everyone goes trifold what was it
do you have it was the plastic that was
cracked that one was cracked it's velcro
crew that's a death leopard velcro while
it was brown too yeah yeah do you um oh
do you have a picture of mom in your
home sorry yeah yeah you do and do you
talk to your daughter about her yeah i
do i say that i might tell her that your
grandmother and that's my mom and my mom
passed away when i was really young now
you got a seven-year-old trying to
comprehend oh my god
you want to go like i i know this is a
side thing but our you know why we rent
a house we rented a house in los angeles
and eagle rock and our landlord lived in
the back house and was like a
grandfather to our daughter and like we
love this guy i mean
never raised rent when the pandemic
started he asked me you guys okay do you
want me to change i said right now we're
good there's no need for you to not have
what you need we can we're fine like
just to check in like that and say hey i
know i'm your landlord but what can we
do that's nice how can we make it work
and we really bonded especially when the
pandemic started and he
on april 30th of 2020 he had a heart
attack and and he passed away no and i i
mean this guy truly
you know here we are on this pandemic
you've just taken my daughter at four
years old we've taken her out of
preschool and said you you know you want
you're not going back and i don't know
when you'll see any of those people
again or those kids who you were like
playing with your friends um and just we
were trying to make the best of it as we
could and then you know that's a month
and a half into hey everything shut down
and he had a heart attack and i
i came back in the the house uh i got
off the phone with someone at the
hospital
who you know the hospitals at that time
like didn't know what to do with co-fed
and so
i was like they're like he didn't make
it and they're they were like i'm not
legally supposed to even tell you this
you're not next of kin or anything and i
was like we live on this property can
you just help me out like where is he is
he okay
and they were like he didn't make it and
i double checked the name and the
address and everything the guy's like
i'm really sorry to find out this way
we're slammed i gotta i gotta get off
the phone i was like okay bye and i hung
up and
i went inside and i just collapsed i
think
my wife probably had a better
relationship with him than i did but i
everything was just inside of me it just
exploded
and i was just like i can't i was like i
grew up in this it's like i don't want
to tell her
she's in bed you know this is at night i
was like tomorrow morning we have to
explain to her that he died
and she's four years old
and
my wife has been reading her this book
called lifetimes that i was like babe
put that what are we doing put that away
and she's like it just talks about how
bugs and animals and humans i was like
it just starts prepping kids
the fact that we got to the next morning
i was like thank god you [ __ ] read
her that book because she will maybe be
able to comprehend this because of that
book
and so i remember having to tell her
uh what had happened and i i'm crying my
wife is crying and she is like you can
tell she doesn't know how to feel about
it you know
it's so strange when someone tells you
someone died
in the movies and tv shows people are
immediately like
shattered but that's truly not real
there's almost a party that doesn't feel
sad right away
first yeah you almost have to get to
that and it's not even like immediate
the shock
sometimes anger before yeah
emote i mean uh being upset yeah but i i
mean i say all that to say that when my
dad died she was down the street at her
friends
and we had said you know they they were
like we'll keep her for the night and so
then the next morning she came back to
the house and
to sit her i mean to sit her down again
this [ __ ] poor kid
and just say
i know we were just here and i told you
this
and i i
my wife we talked about it i was like
i don't want her to think that everyone
just dies i was like i don't want her to
develop a thing of like
well i better be careful about love
because it's easier
if everyone's gonna die anyways i was
like i don't want that to happen
and to tell her
you know you lost your grandfather and
it's my dad and trying to explain you
know it's a kid they can't fully
comprehend it right anyways but man i'll
tell you what crushed me i mean as an
adult and i've been through it a bunch
like you i still don't fully comprehend
it yeah you know and then if it's what
it is and changes and now you gotta now
i'm now i went through this as a kid and
i have to try to explain this to a kid
but i didn't even know what the [ __ ]
that was i still don't know what the
[ __ ] that was i was 16 then yeah i'm 48
now there's a big difference yeah and
i'm just trying to explain it to her i'm
getting all kinds of [ __ ] anxiety
this is happening i know of course i'm
getting horses it's everywhere it's
it's it's [ __ ] dracula's goddamn
biting at us
um but yeah to explain that to her i
think her my dad would have had so much
in common the more she's like aged and
who she is
like that we play games and stuff and
she [ __ ] talks and i'm like [ __ ] my dad
would have loved that [ __ ] like that's
what i thought my daughter she tells me
[ __ ] when i put something down she'd
just be like i wasn't too smart to do
that was it as a kid
you thought that was good huh that's my
daughter does i'm like your
there's so much of you in him like in
how you respond and say stuff but that's
got to feel a little good too though
yeah it does and there's also this part
of me that you know you start to
uh
this this is maybe a sort of a full
circle of this conversation but
there's this part of me that's like well
my mom died on my first birthday so i
dedicate myself to going you know what
i'm gonna try to live this big life and
do something extraordinary whatever that
is and so here i am in
in the world of
doing stand-up and acting and being like
well there that's that's a unique
pursuit and the fact that i've even been
able to buy groceries off of it is
already that means i crossed the finish
line in terms of
of getting to where i was trying to get
to no matter what happens if you're
supporting your family off of your
talent then you are that's the american
dream professional to have a job
here yeah to have a job you like that is
the american dream so i
i i
i had that and then you know when my dad
passed away i thought you know i i feel
like i i obviously had to leave to go i
moved to dc and then i moved to new york
city and i moved to l.a
and
once he was gone i was like god there's
now this part of me it's like i feel
like i left i feel like
you know if he's like oh yeah maybe i
maybe we would have really hit it off me
and your daughter but you guys weren't
here or i didn't see you so well that
yeah but that's but but it's it's a
thing that you just go there isn't
there's no winning to it you just you
look and you go
oh i don't i don't know how you get to
have
uh
all of those things
but
the other strange thing is that
i go in to stand up to
to have this extraordinary life as a
dedication to my mother for the
sacrifice she made uh only to have my
dad pass away and for me to realize oh i
was only doing this to for you i was
doing this so that you would look so
that you would go wait what did you say
like if i have this microphone
and all these people are watching the
lights are pointing up here then you're
gonna look up here and you'll you'll
hear what i'm saying and i i gotta say
to
obviously we're in a pandemic i haven't
been on stage very much but it's not the
same space for me anymore what i do is
now not the same space as what it once
was where i had this this you know
you're obviously trying to sell tickets
and have an audience but
to be faced with the fact that you
realize you just cared about one
audience member the whole time
really changes
so much stuff in your mind and your
approach to
how to care about the thing
that you were doing
as a as a as a dedication to your mother
who died and then your dad dies to
realize
oh i was doing this for you
this wasn't this wasn't for her all
right two things you have a new audience
yeah of one your daughter now right
that's the person who matters that's
watching you now yeah which is what your
dad would want anyway if your dad was
like look i'm done watching this [ __ ]
show i'm gonna give my ticket to
somebody it's gonna be your daughter
secondly actually three things because
your dad did love what you did he just
didn't tell you yeah like you wish he
would have but everybody else [ __ ]
came over and told you
and um also
it's it's tough because i
my mom didn't because my mom left our
family but your dad also made a
sacrifice your dad was a single [ __ ]
dad with two kids for a minute brought
in
uh aunt connie she's putting all [ __ ]
what do you call it additional education
higher education on pause yeah and then
you have a stepmom and i mean i'm
assuming that was she was a good woman
your dad brought her and trusted her
around his kids and all that so your mom
made the ultimate sacrifice but so did
your dad your dad made a huge sacrifice
as well so i think it's cool that you
wanted him to see it i think he and he
obviously did yeah yeah but now
the space is different but you should
change that [ __ ] start painting a new
painting for your daughter now yeah i i
mean it it
really it's funny to say i've started
painting actually um painting actually
i do it i do come here every now and
then i go to the garage i get high pour
some wine or uh old fashioned put on
some some jazz and i just start [ __ ]
painting and it's if anyone is looking
going i need something to release
go paint it is so great and don't sit
there and go was it good or bad no one
[ __ ] just paint and you'll be like
god this is fun
and use your hands [ __ ] finger paint
get a brush smear [ __ ] it's so goddamn
uh therapeutic but uh
yeah it's it it really
there's a good and bad to it to realize
that you've been doing it all for this
reason
there's something that clicks for you to
go well now there's this there's this
other reason and i will say
um and yes i i totally agree like well
now there's your daughter and this but i
i will say it's now the first time that
i've been like well what if uh you know
what what would you do if you're if
you're your own audience
then what would you do because before it
really mattered this other person's
thing but what does art become if it no
longer matters to you about any other
person
and it's just what you think is fun
and i won't lie i don't know when i'll
hit hit the ground running and start
doing spots all the time like i used to
do and get on the road like i used to do
but i am excited to see what it becomes
i think it's gonna be very painful and i
think it's gonna be very quiet for a lot
of a lot of the time but i i think
somewhere in there um talking about the
painting somewhere in there there is a
painting i like and i got to go through
a lot of
uh [ __ ]
think about think about when you do a
head shots they'll take 80 of them all
you're looking for is a one i know
i just need one that doesn't disgust me
of my own [ __ ] face please i hope you
got it in that pile yeah and they're
like well this one where you're holding
up your hand covering most of it
that's it that's the one
it's funny you say that because
you know i just recently was passed at
the comedy store and for all these years
22 years i've wanted to make my dad
proud my grandma i wanted the world to
see my name on that building and now
that i have it now if i would have got
it then
that's what i would have thought and now
all i care about is my daughter
my stepson their kids seeing that on the
wall you know what i mean i was able to
shift that be like you know what yeah
and i keep it's so funny i keep
listening to i want to i'm going to
manifest this i want joan jett on this
podcast i love joan jett she's an oriole
fan there aren't many of us left
i'd love to sit down and talk to her we
could go over a whole episode on that
[ __ ] [ __ ] squad but i say just say
that i know i'm interrupting you but
just saying that my dad was hardcore
braves
i was watching a a soccer game at the
soccer stadium when the braves won the
world series and i mean
i almost collapsed and someone had been
like i you love the brave so i'm like i
don't even i like them all right they've
been like what do you what are you
you're pouring tears like you just
pitched the last pitch to win the
[ __ ]
game and you played for them your whole
career and i've been like it's a long
story to go into it but i remember
the moment they threw that pitch and and
they just needed one more
out i was just like [ __ ] like it
it hit me hard and i just remember those
the 90s watching the braves was
i mean that what a team to cheer for
in the 90s you know i keep listening to
her song bad reputation and she says
you're living in the past it's a new
generation i'm like yeah and i i i get
these i see these questions if you could
tell i'm which i'm going to ask you
about your 16 year old self but i just
recently realized that when i see these
things that say
think back to a time you were truly
happy yeah
my mind is trained to always go back to
childhood
always i'm always looking for it in
there yeah when i'm like you're 48 dude
15 years ago right you know what i'm
saying like 33 you could have been so
[ __ ] happy why does your mind always
go to
7 to 10. you know what i mean yeah and
because i guess because before the [ __ ]
show started i was i was happy like i
feel like i had a good childhood up
until
death showed up i was like yeah guys
we're gonna [ __ ] that all up yeah and it
hits you i've told this story before but
you'll i'm gonna tell you this because
you'll get a kick out of this so
it's a couple like thanksgivings ago
before the pandemic or whatever and um
i go in it's it's actually christmas and
i'm always do a traditional thing my
grandma was italian so we had the
traditional foods and then we would have
italian options so i'm going to get some
[ __ ] to make some italian food and i go
up to there's no one in line at the the
deli meat counter so i'm like wow i'm
here i'm gonna go order some cold cuts
and i'm gonna shop and i'll come back
and grab them that's the move so this
older lady comes out
and she's got an italian accent she's
like what would you like and i'm like
let me get some boar's head low sodium
number two cut it as thin as you can
without shaving and she's like okay i'll
go i'm gonna be right back i'm gonna
grab a couple things and i'll come back
she goes stay here talk to me i'm like
okay
and i start talking to her and she's
she's asking me like what i'm doing i'm
like i'm getting the italian food you
know i start telling her that i didn't
know
until i started dating other girls and
stuff and going to their homes that
people didn't always have italian food
because every [ __ ] relative was
italian like i'm an idiot i don't figure
it out and yeah we're going back and
she's telling me her her daughter's
dating this guy and this and that and um
i go yeah you know it's the older
generation i really just miss the older
generation so much
and i'm telling her all about my grandma
i'm like every time i go there the
smells and the smells yeah and
she gives me the ham and i'm like thank
you so much and i go what's your name
and she goes carmella and i go did you
just say carmella she goes yeah i go
that's my grandmom's name yeah and i get
my credit card out because i named my
business stella my daughter carmella my
grandmom yeah bro i'm crying of course
of course you are oh look at this yeah
there's people like wait like can i get
some corn people i'm just having this
[ __ ] moment with the [ __ ] lady
hard you know oh my god yeah thank you
for making me stay thank you
it's like the closest hello i'll ever
[ __ ] get from my grandma you're like
oh you walk off tears snot
is the next person funny enough to look
at her and go uh i'll have what he's
having like are they funny and also is
carmella even getting that
life is like that like get the [ __ ] out
of here so give me a half pound of rose
while you're telling that story
when you were telling that story right
at the moment where she said stay here
and just talk to me for a second that
right then i almost said to you
i was interrupting you to say i wonder
if people know
like that like there's angels among us
but they are just us like because
there's a moment where a guy is speeding
off for getting away from you and you're
like hold on one second once again where
did you get those shoes yeah and that
guy doesn't know he needs you to ask him
that right right then and that moment
where he're just saying stay here and
talk to me i bet you that is not all the
time it was the closest thing to a hug
yeah i'm ever going to [ __ ] get
that's the kind of time i think you put
in a movie you should write the down
code this is a scene for a character
openly weeping at the [ __ ] deli
counter yeah everyone's there it's no
one when i get there and now there's six
[ __ ] people and she's by herself you
know i don't know
and even she's like you gotta move on
i'm not her i'm not her bud i'm not put
your card away pay at the register i'm
not hurt
i'm just bored i just bored for a second
oh
[ __ ] dude thank you for coming on this
has been a [ __ ] great episode thank
you for having me i appreciate this all
right so before you plug again i ask
everyone their first time on sometimes i
forget i do forget sometimes yeah i
forgot nick schwartz and i forgot to ask
we'll have to get him back to ask his 16
year old me but please
after what we've talked about now
knowing what you were at uh going
through at that age uh what advice would
you give 16 year old rory i
i think i would
tell myself to
to listen more and to genuinely listen
not not the kind of listening that i
still do actively kind of listening
where you're just kind of thinking what
you're going to say because a lot of
times our trigger is oh i got a good one
yeah so then you wait for your timing to
get it in
and you kind of miss some good [ __ ] and
i feel like i feel like i i would be a
different person today if
instead of being so me me me at 16 which
we all are we're teenagers but i wish
i was less me me me and more
well you're talking so i'm gonna
actually actively listen and ask you
about you as opposed to
waiting for that moment where i get to
just talk about
me and my myself i think as i get older
you just get so [ __ ] tired of that
you get so tired of of
uh
the the internal
like i need people to know i mean i know
the irony of saying it on a podcast
where you just interviewed me about
stuff
but you know what i mean where it's
still there when you're not on a podcast
and someone's like i didn't ask you
about your dad bro it's like sorry i
just i'll get some roast beef and some
ham and turkey
[Laughter]
oh
[ __ ] but as you shuffle off in your
[ __ ] adidas slippers exactly
but i just i i would tell my
six-year-old self like
you know
uh
listen more and and don't be so
don't don't be so afraid of adults don't
don't look at adults as these mega
authoritative figures and start to talk
to them i think if i didn't look at
adults like that there's a chance maybe
i would open up to my dad
i think all of a sudden though we're a
generation that was taught to fear and
and shut up and listen and go over there
and sit at the kids table mind your
business and yes you know it wasn't a
very open time to have that so that's
great yeah um plug whatever you'd like
again please yeah uh pen pals podcast um
it's with daniel van kirk and myself we
get letters from our our listeners who
write us about random [ __ ] and we we get
into it it's it's not so unlike this we
dive into the funny stuff we dive into
the real uh the real dramatic stuff as
well and
so i would say
check that out and then physical on
apple tv plus and then hopefully at some
point in 2022 i'll have some club dates
coming but i don't know when or whatever
get that website going talking about all
right as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you